when a nine million dollar movie makes
over 150 million dollars at the box
office you can
bet that movie's getting a sequel
luckily the surprise 2019 hit escape
room left things all set up for a
follow-up coming this summer in escape
room tournament of champions
the first escape room hit theaters in
january 2019 where it turned a massive
profit in the face of little opposition
with that kind of success few were
surprised when it was announced the next
month
that work had already begun on a sequel
to escape room deadline reported that
studio sony pictures releasing
had tapped director adam robitel and two
of his creative colleagues on the movie
screenwriter bray g f shoot and producer
neil h moritz to get to work on escape
room 2
tentatively set for release on april 17
2020.
sony executives were evidently blown
away by the film's success
the first escape room received only
modest compliments from viewers as of
june 2021 the first movie has a 51
ranking from critics and audiences both
but the fact that the movie has made
so much money in spite of those middling
reviews
made it an easy decision to green light
and fast track a sequel
after all it's not every day that a
movie made for less than 10 million
dollars
makes more than 15 times that amount at
the box office
two months went by before anyone heard
much else about the impending escape
room movie
then in april 2019 robitel sat down for
an exclusive interview with bloody
disgusting and gave audiences their
first hint
of where the sequel might be going that
includes expanding the mythology behind
the evil minos organization
behind the original movie's escape room
which he referred to
as a machiavellian company that knows
everything about you
the filmmaker said it was tough
admittedly to pull back the veil and
i know some people are like oh this is
about rich people watching
people get killed but there's some cool
mythology that we're trying to bring in
the second movie
i think the fact that they could hijack
a plane whether it's literal or
figurative
there's something cool about that it's
pushed for sure but we think
hopefully the audience is going for the
ride
this is way bigger than last time gotta
try something right
the hollywood landscape may be littered
with sequels remakes spin-offs and
cinematic universes but the fact remains
that it's actually pretty hard to make
that first sequel to a movie
you're essentially trying to
simultaneously recapture lightning in a
bottle
and expand on an existing story in a way
that not only makes sense
but is also entertaining one wrong move
can spell the difference between a
one-off sequel and a full-blown
franchise
all that considered it's not too
surprising to hear director adam robitel
confess that the tournament of champions
filmmakers faced some creative
challenges in the early days of
development on their escape room sequel
robitille explained to blighty
disgusting that the biggest obstacle to
overcome was deciding what type of
escape rooms to include in the sequel
since the first movie already utilized a
lot of different
themes he said we did fire gravity
ice cold gas so we need to outdo
ourselves now
we have some really cool stuff we're
developing and hopefully the audience
will think that way too but it's
tougher we did do the greatest hits in
the first movie so the road gets
narrower as it goes on
how do you give the audience what
they're expecting from an escape room
movie but also
not the exact same thing that the first
movie did so
we're really trying to iron all that out
right now
thankfully it took only a few months for
the minds behind escape room tournament
of champions to sort
everything out and settle on a script
that they were pleased with once they
reached that milestone the next order of
business was auditioning and selecting
actors to be in the sequel's cast
there were six players in the original
escape room film however
as is normal for a movie like this all
six players don't manage to survive the
game in fact
only two of the six members of the group
managed to escape taylor russell is zoe
and logan miller is ben in the process
of surviving the game the unlikely duo
uncovers a vast corporate conspiracy
that involves high stakes betting on who
if any of the players might make it out
of the game alive
both of those characters will be back
for the escape room sequel with russell
and miller reprising their respective
roles
that's not really a shock seeing as
though their return is essentially set
up in the final moments of escape room
since a new game is officially a foot
for tournament of champions
new faces will be joining zoe and ben
thomas kokorel will play nathan
teen wolf alum holland rhoden will
portray rachel
and india moore of post spain is set for
the role of brianna
while orphan breakout is belfurman and
step up high waters carlito oliveiro
round out the game's roster of six
players
as for who these characters are well the
title of the sequel
sort of spills the beans there they're
all winners of past games brought back
for a championship tournament to
determine who's the best of the bunch
no no no it's happening again you guys
have played the game before
so what is this like a tournament of
champions
details on each character beyond zoe and
ben are scarce for right now
though director adam robitaille did tell
cinemablend that each champion will have
a mysterious backstory pertaining to the
struggles they went through
prior to their involvement in the
tournament of champions he said
what i try to do is set up questions for
each of them like i did in the first
movie
we're leaning into why does this person
have a scar
and why is this guy seemingly reading
the last rights to somebody
there's one character who has an
anomalous immune system
and so there's weird things that happen
with pain and so we're setting up all
these questions
proving that they're not your average
characters i
can't feel physical pain just imagine
the kinds of puzzles they came up with
for me
way back when escape room 2 was first
announced sony pictures releasing
stamped it with an april 17
2020 release date at the time it seemed
like a perfect debut date
there would be enough time between the
first and second movies to allow hype to
build and
launching it in the spring rather than
the summer meant there wouldn't be the
risk of massive tentpole productions
crushing it at the box office
but of course escape room tournament of
champions never did arrive in theaters
on that day
after multiple delays escape room
tournament of champions was shuffled
around multiple release dates in 2020
then 2021
before finally landing all the way in
january 7th
2022 but then in april 2021 deadline
reported that the movie was moving
back through time to land in theaters
later that year on july 16th
viewers in australia can see the film
even earlier as it opens down under on
july 1st
when we last saw zoe and ben they made a
pact to confront the masterminds of the
first movie's deadly game
but as the audience saw those mysterious
master game makers were already a few
steps ahead of them
the final moments of escape room teased
that the organization's shadowy
mastermind was already plotting a new
near
impossible to survive game to be played
on the duo's flight to new york
from the tournament of champions trailer
it seemed zoe and ben
either survived or dodged that game on
route to new york
they still get ensnared in a new game
though and this one opens on a subway
car with a handful of strangers
as alluded to in the film's title those
strangers are all survivors of past
games
it's the finals of the jeopardy
tournament of champions
it's mine according to returning
director adam robe tell escape room
tournament of champions
will reveal that the scale of minos
organization is far larger than even the
first movie hinted at
he told cinema cinemablend what we're
going to realize is that on any given
day there are multiple games happening
all around the world by bringing back
zoe ben
and a group of other champions to face
the dangers of an escape room again
robitel also noted of the sequel it's
sort of a meditation on trauma and how
people deal with trauma
but also what they've learned through
their first trial by fire
while escape room tournament of
champions doesn't appear to be venturing
too far from the first film's formula
from the look of things the filmmakers
have really outdone themselves in terms
of both
game and production design the sequel
will presumably have its fair share of
shocking twists and reveals too
as for who's going to make it out of the
new game unscathed
your guest is as good as ours with
escape room tournament of champions
hitting theaters in mere weeks we'll all
find out soon enough if you can't make
it to the theater when escape room
tournament of champions debuts on july
16th you may be wondering whether the
film will have a simultaneous streaming
release like many other movies have this
year
the answer is sadly pretty disappointing
escape room tournament of champions
isn't going to be streaming anywhere
anytime soon
adam robotel explained the decision when
speaking with cinema blend in may 2021
in the director's opinion horror movies
should be seen in theaters where it's
dark
quiet and free from outside distractions
the perfect environment to be scared
out of your mind he put an artful spin
on the subject
sharing the latin root of the word
horror means to bristle on the back of
the neck
it's the one genre that has a physical
and physiological influence over the
audience
it's manipulating them people love to be
afraid in groups they love to go on
dates to scream and grab their popcorn
escape room tournament of champions will
likely be available to watch from the
comfort of your own home
sometime in the future but for now
you'll just have to head to the cinema
to see it
starting on july 16th check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
movies and tv shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you